let's get to this man because
because he's missing out on some crucial
information that's going down right now
on the nfl network
um
nfl media group uh talent zoom prior to
the uh the season where we're hearing
about points of emphasis and stuff like
that folks are taking copious notes from
me right now
i'm missing it and i i i told daniel
jeremiah just turn your camera off they
have no idea if you're not on the zoom
and you're on the rich eisen show so dj
thanks for doing this appreciate it
yeah there's probably a hundred percent
chance i'll be the one that gets called
on here
what are you being called on like what's
what's going on what is happening right
now i just i just feel like i've never
i've done very few things to get myself
in trouble over the years rich but i i'm
caught every time as a kid so i just
figure you know we're gonna play a
little hooky have a little conversation
here uh off the zoom off the network
summit zoom and i'm sure there'll be
like some
random point where uh where my name will
be brought up and dj you want to chime
in here and then you know i'm not there
but i'm i'm okay with that i'm i'll take
the risk for for you i'll take the hit
daniel because i'm i'm you know uh in in
nine days i'm uh hosting the
ribbon-cutting ceremony for the new
studio so you know i think i'm in good
standing there
uh you're waiting
on that one i guess that's not good i'll
take the hit i'll take the head daniel i
don't know
if you want me you want to be my plus
one
you bring the scissors you bring the
scissors you're my plus one
yeah the big scissors oh i've always
wanted them i've always wanted the big
check and then the big scissors those
are like
daniel jeremiah here on the rich eisen
show all right man uh what did you see
out of trey lance yesterday that makes
you think something what do you got for
me well on that well i just they had
held off on any of the design
quarterback stuff now they they did a
little bit of it they sprinkled some of
it in with trey lance yesterday and
that's what got me fired up now one of
them's a touchdown it's a four-yard run
and i kind of i posted that and i said
oh watch out like here we go
and people
freak out and say oh it's backups versus
backups it's a four-yard run we've seen
this before what's the big deal and i'm
sitting here going no no
i'm watching
knowing what trey lance can do as a
runner
and now i'm saying okay they're gonna
kind of unleash this thing in some way
shape or form whether that's just when
they get down inside the red zone
whether that's on third and shorts are
they going to sprinkle them in
throughout the game i i got a feeling
that something's coming there rich and
he might not be starting but we're going
to see trey lance and we're going to get
a chance to see them line up
and as a defense you're going to see
debo samuel in the slot you're gonna see
george kittle lined up next to trent
williams who you know arguably the best
left tackle in the nfl and you're gonna
have a big time speed back next to trey
lance and you're gonna have to wonder
are they getting ready to pound this
thing down my throat are they going to
go play action and all of a sudden now
george kittle just ran by me are they
going to flip it to debo samuel coming
across the formation or are they going
to fake all that crap and trey lance is
going to take off like
there is so much you're going to have to
deal with uh defensively and to game
plan against i mean i i can't wait i
think it's gonna be a nightmare to
defend when he gets in the game yeah i
mean when you tweeted out that play um
it looked quite exotic to me certainly
for a pre-season snap that looked like
okay
this is what they're hiding or planning
and cultivating
so are you saying that maybe lance gets
in
to the game once they enter the red zone
10-yard line like is that what you're
you're you're thinking what shanahan
might be thinking here for 2021
i mean i think everything's on the table
you know is he going to be given a maybe
he's given a drive here and there maybe
it's you get into you know short yardage
situations he comes out there maybe it's
just down in the red zone
eventually
it's going to be his job once he further
develops in the passing game and you're
going to have to deal with all this
stuff on an every down basis
but in the but in the meantime i think
they're going to find ways just my
opinion watching it to be able to
incorporate him and use a pretty a
pretty unique skill set that he has uh
with the creativity
uh that you have with kyle shanahan so
uh it'll be it'll be fascinating i know
one thing you got to prepare for it no
matter how much of it they're going to
do
you got to spend a good chunk of time
preparing for all that stuff yeah and i
uh the detroit lions i believe are first
up for them as jared goff can't quit the
the nfc west in his first game with the
lion so
you're saying that lance's
uh passing game maturity is what
potentially
is gonna put garoppolo out there to
start that game for for the 49ers that's
the decision that's coming do you think
yeah i mean i i just
i think that that's the way it looks to
me is that you know seeing them practice
out in person and then watching through
the preseason trey's got some stuff to
clean up as a passer he's going to have
some some misses everything is hot
coming out of his hand man it has got
some big time juice so i'll learn to
touch some things up a little bit um i
think jimmy's just he's more accurate at
this point in time so
i think that's going to close i think
that gap is going to close and then
you're going to get all the big
playability not just as a runner but
just with your pure arm strength being
able to stretch the field vertically
that trey is going to bring so
you know i i still if you're asking me
to project i still think we see him as
the starter uh at some point time this
season and maybe they'll announce it's
week one but my expectation would be
it's probably jimmy and you're gonna
sprinkle trey lance and then i think at
some point time during the season he'll
have evolved and grown enough to get
kyle's trust and and and the regular
offense that they run that uh you get
your cake and eat it too daniel jeremiah
here on the rich eisen show at move the
sticks on twitter he and bucky brooks
have a podcast by the same name you
should all check out right here on the
rich eisen show what do you think is
going through belichick's mind what's
the evaluation there
between cam and mac and vice versa
yeah i just went and watched uh all the
mac stuff this morning kind of just want
to go back through and refresh it and
just watch all his cut ups
man when he is when he is on time when
he sees it his back foot is down and the
ball is out i mean rich it's he's making
good decisions the ball is with
excellent excellent ball placement not
just accuracy ball placement right up
field shoulder guys can run after the
catch he's throwing guys away from
defenders um some really really good
stuff now there were some plays in that
game yesterday
when there wasn't anywhere to go with
the football and it kind of closed in on
him and that was the you saw kind of the
downside with mac right you're not going
to get that creativity you're not going
to get the escape ability
to be able to make plays
um but you know we could have had the
same knock on the on the previous guy
that was there for 20 years and uh they
have a pretty good idea of how to work
around that so
um it seems like a perfect marriage
i know cam having started all the
preseason games i guess that would point
towards him but
golly you know if you're asking me kind
of what i think would be best for them i
yes i i think he'd be fine i think i
would throw mac jones out there week one
and there's going to be some growing
pains along the way but it didn't you
know it's a pre-season but it didn't
look big it did not look big for him
yeah and i i'm i'm kind of of the same
way too certainly you know
and i know that this this would
definitely get an eye roll out of the
coach i would assume but
but you know week four brady's coming in
wouldn't you want mac jones to get up to
speed right uh as a unless unless you
think cam can really take you to the
playoffs this year and then you just
give mack a sabbatical year and just go
for it as long as you can with cam like
maybe that
you know what about that is a
possibility certainly as they're
flipping sony michelle off to the rams
because their running back crew seems to
be so damn deep yeah what do you think
about that
no i mean i think they'll be fine with
cam you know they're gonna you know if
that's the case they're gonna run it
really well and play great defense and
special teams and and they can win a lot
of football games i just think right now
um i i think mack is in a better place
in the passing game
and i think this is kind of the floor
for him he's only going to get better so
if it's close i think everybody even if
you're going to say they should start
cam i think everybody would have to
agree it's pretty close
so if it's close
and one guy is kind of you know at the
floor of what he's going to be i would
just be more inclined to say you know
what mac jones is good enough right now
and he's going to get better um so
that's that's but again coach belichick
is is
way more in the details with everything
going on and what their plan is for the
season and and we won't know that until
he announces it that's for sure daniel
jeremiah here on the rich eisen show so
maybe trevor lawrence didn't really earn
the job it was his all along and they
were just trying to
get
trade value up and nobody ran for that
head fake took that okey doke at all
um what'd you think of trevor lawrence
in his final preseason action looking
the way he did against dallas
yeah he looked crisp and and i actually
thought
you know even in the new orleans game
where you know that protection wasn't
great i i saw improvement from him each
week which that's the goal right if
you're if you're a rookie starter um i
was talking about this with somebody the
other day you're saying kind of what are
the mistakes that
rookies make and i said well
it's usually the comparison thing right
it's putting pressure on yourself you're
looking around at other players of your
position and you're feeling that
pressure to outplay them or you're a
high pick and you're looking to prove
everybody right for why you were a high
pick or you're a low pick you're looking
to prove everybody wrong the the goal is
just you want to just get better each
week and so when you watch trevor
lawrence from all the way through the
preseason i saw steady improvement and i
know guys aren't playing i hear all the
you know everybody wants to poo poo
everything but i'd be encouraged if i
was a jags fan that this this kid with
all this talent all this ability is
getting better each week well we know
he's the one there and we know zach
wilson's uh the the qb qb1
uh in new york we just discussed san
francisco in new england that leaves the
last uh topic of conversation in this
subject with you daniel jeremiah about
the bear's decision to sit justin fields
and start dalton for week one and then
who knows what what do you think of that
choice by matt nagy
well i mean it
i understand it from from his experience
and looking at the kansas city thing i
just think it's apples to oranges that
you know i to me i think justin fields
is mentally and physically tough enough
to be able to withstand
whatever comes his way early in the
season whatever failure comes his way i
think i think the kid's built for i
think he'll be fine he sure as heck is
going to provide a lot more juice and
excitement within the within the locker
room the team and and a much wider sense
of fan base
so yeah i i'd want to get him up and
running my goal if i'm you know
everybody's in a different phase as a
team right my goal for the chicago bears
is
i want to get his mistakes over with as
fast as possible right so let's get him
out there let him learn let him make
those mistakes the first four six eight
games and then the back half of the
season we're going to see all this
ability from this really talented player
start to come through and whatever our
record is at the end of the year there's
going to be a palpable buzz and
excitement about what kind of football
justin fields is playing late in the
season and where this team's going to be
a year from now two years from now five
years from now guys have a feeling you
wait and all of a sudden you say oh
we're gonna let him play the last four
or five games he's gonna go through kind
of the struggle period the adjustment
period and then the season's over so i i
would i would roll him out there
personally and what do you think the
dolphins are seeing in tua and
and last year this year to lead to the
possibility of
on the eve of the season saying we're
not going to give up on acquiring
deshaun watson is too a problem in miami
like what are you what what's what's on
his tape
daniel no i i thought he's looked good
in in the preseason i thought he's got a
little more life in his legs
um you know another year removed from
that hip injury i thought some of that
twitch that you liked about him that i
liked about him coming through the draft
process you know quick release quick
setup you know quick decisions balls out
now he's not as talented as deshawn
watson desean watson is a rare talent
you know i so to me it'd be more about
the opportunity of of bringing in a
super talented player and desean watson
more than a
kind of a verdict on two is going to be
a bust i think two is going to be a good
player
but i'm not you know i i think that if
you ask me where does deshaun watson
ultimately end up i would say you know
you're looking at miami you're looking
at philadelphia those would be the two
that i would that i would point to but i
just i'm not buying that any of this
stuff can go down until we have more
resolution on the situation i know this
is reports out saying well there can be
conditions if this happens if that
happens i just i can't
i just can't fathom pulling pulling the
trigger on that trade and bringing him
in with all of this stuff hanging out
there how do you do that i just know how
you do it yeah i mean you you know what
it's like to put a deal together daniel
i mean how could you even come up with
you know games played snaps played
suspensions avoided or absorbed to
figure out whether a two becomes a three
or a one or a four and it becomes a two
and i can't even imagine there's no
chart for that sort of thing no there's
no there's no precedent
um and man you talk about
you talk about putting your coach in a
tough spot i mean
have that press conference i mean maybe
i mean good nice
i just don't i just don't see how you
can do it i i you know we'll see hope
maybe all this stuff gets resolved here
and once it does get resolved i would
imagine it won't take long before
something would get done or at least
those teams would try to get something
done to bring him in but then i put on
the houston texans hat and i'm saying
okay well if all this legal stuff gets
resolved
and i've just traded for all these draft
picks and deshawn watson ends up playing
more than half of the games with this
new team they're more than likely going
to win more games and now i've just
parted with the franchise quarterback
who's young
and i'm going to end up with a bunch of
middle first round picks i mean i'd
rather wait till the season was over
let's look at the teams who have top
five picks those are the only ones we're
talking to well that's something we were
talking about why the green bay if they
were going to trade aaron rodgers do it
after the season rather than trade them
before and then watch the draft choices
you just acquired get worse you know i
mean you know you at least you you trade
them for draft choices where you know
they're already fixed in in the top five
best you can figure that out and i i
don't know where you are i don't know
you know i haven't done all of the
season uh prediction stuff that
everybody's asked to do i currently do
not have the houston texans winning the
super bowl
uh i would wait i would just just wait
way to get out on that very very thin
limb uh daniel way to take that risk
before i let you go i am going to
utilize your insight uh to help me
formulate my sleeper team for the afc i
give you one for each uh conference
before the season and i'm circling
around the chargers right now uh we
spoke to brandon staley last week i just
love every word out of his mouth and
then you know in the same way that we
talked about you know you want to put
justin fields out there because get his
mistakes out early he's got a fully
formed
second year quarterback as opposed to
putting herbert out there for the first
time and going through lumps and
and even though that was a hell of a
lumpy rookie season for him last year uh
but it seems with everybody there's
playmakers on almost every damn level on
every part of that
roster
what do you think about the charger
season since you and matt money smith
will be calling those games locally here
yeah los angeles yeah we uh well first
of all we're both very happy that the
preseason is over and the regular season
has arrived because of uh
kind of the adoption of the don't play
any starters uh philosophy that brandon
staley brought over from from sean mcvay
so i'm excited to get a chance to see
all these front-line players get out
there against washington
um and
money and i were talking about this the
other night rich this is
to me i think it's got a chance to be
the best offensive line they've had in a
decade um and that's something philip
rivers just wasn't afforded to have that
consistent offensive line play they have
a chance to have a really not just an
okay offensive line a really good
offensive line
um so that's going to be crucial if they
can stay healthy up front along the
offensive line they're going to score a
boatload of points because keenan
allen's you know a premier route runner
austin eckler out in space is going to
be a nightmare for teams
and then you flip it over to the
defensive side of the ball you've got
an elite pass rusher in bosa derwin
james stays healthy with brandon
staley's creativity he's going to be all
over the field and i think it's one of
the more talented deeper linebacker
groups in the nfl i i don't know that
many people know know this group but
when you see kenneth murray in this
scheme he is going to go nuts uh in this
and kaiser white and drew tranquil these
guys are all low four five speed guys
and so it's gonna be uh it's gonna be a
really really good defense again at all
to me it comes down to the offensive
line if they keep if they keep the
offensive line healthy they're gonna win
a lot of games well before i hear it uh
let you go in before i hear it from my
guys here is is it possible to put a
division winner like pittsburgh as a
sleeper team is that possible to do
something like that because nobody's
talking about them everybody thinks
they're going to stink and i don't
believe it you know yeah after the after
the kind of collapse after the start
last year right i i talk about the
offensive line for the chargers and how
improved it is it's a tbd on the
offensive line for the steelers there's
so many new faces up there that's the
only thing that concerns me i think
ben's arms healthy enough to be able to
push it more vertically than we saw last
year the question i have is are they
going to be able to protect them in
order to get that accomplished so um i i
know i know one thing watching their
pre-season games if they don't run the
ball
uh don't be afraid to still have nadja
harris on your fantasy team because he
might catch 90 balls that'll be the run
game okay good information excellent
nugget go you are now free to return to
the symposium turn your camera back on
yeah
tell them i want still gainfully
employed you still
i'll see you at the ribbon cutting you
take care see you buddy all right man
that's daniel jeremiah move the sticks
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here